واحده من اكثر الدول اللي منتشره فيها
عصابات المخدرات والجريمه المنظمه
المعروفه بالكرتال وهذه العصابات قويه
ولها نفود كبير يعني اكبر مثال على
الموضوع انه اليوم رئيس الدوله بيتهم اكبر
كرتل في البلد بانها مسؤوله عن انهيار
اتفاقيه وقف اطلاق نار عبر دعم هجمات
لعمال مناجم غير نظاميه عموما هذا مو
خبرنا يعني انا بس بوريكم انه بدي ايش قوه
وانتشار عصابات المخدرات في كولومبيا عشان
كده لما يكون في خبر عن ضبط شحنه مخدرات
في كولومبيا بالمبدا يعني مو خبر مستغرب
او غير معهود يعني لكن تفاصيل شحنه اليوم
هي اللي حكايه مختلفه الصراحه في اللي صار
انه في وحده من او في وحده من البحريه
الكولومبيه كانت بتلف دوريات عاديه كده في
مياهها المحيط ولقي السفينه عايمه في وسط
المياه لوحدها يعني وقام وقفوا وتفقدوها
لقوا فيها اربع اشخاص ميتين ومعاهم اكثر
من اثنين طن مخدرات
[موسيقى]
مشهد مثل الافلام والله يعني شفتوا
المخدرات كيف كده اكوام اكوام شفتوا كميه
عناصر الامن اللي بينقلوا فيها وداخل
السفينه كان في 2643 طن كوكايين السلطات
بتقول انها كانت في طريقها لدول امريكا
الوسطى ورغم انه بدايه حامد تساؤلات
وشبهات حول موت الاربعه ركاب اللي في
السفينه لكن اتضح حسب السلطات انهم ماتوا
متسممين بغسان من عوادم السفينه يعني ما
في شبهه جنائيه يعني على فكره السفينه
يعني مو اي كلام اي كلام بنتكلم نحن عن
سفينه طولها 15 متر ارتفاعها منخفض وتوصف
بان شبيهه بالغواصات